have you guys thought about light do you
know what the next of Enders team looks
like yes and it will be it will be a
very different team than we've seen
before that's what endgame was all about
yeah
Marvel has officially announced phase
four of the MCU and it's really exciting
there are a lot of exciting movies
coming up within the next couple of
years and even though we just got a
vengers in game many fans are wondering
if and when we're going to get a next
Avengers film well you've just heard it
from the president of Marvel Studios
himself Kevin Feige there is a new
avengers team in the works that is going
to be built up over the next couple of
phases and not only is there going to be
a new avengers team and film there's
also going to be a new major crossover
event that is going to happen in a movie
and Kevin Feige did confirm this in the
same interview with MTV are you already
planting the seeds for the next
crossover event for if it's Secret Wars
or what like the space for start to
plant the seeds for whatever we're gonna
see yes we've planned them out we've got
five years down the road so we have a
new Avengers team coming and a big
crossover event coming as well so let's
break it all down quick reminder about
my massive giveaway at 500,000
subscribers I'll be picking a few
winners and one will get an Xbox one or
a ps4 the winner gets to choose and
others will get Marvel Legends items so
make sure you subscribe to my channel
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway now we already know for the
most part who the new Avengers team is
going to be thanks to the release of the
phase 4 movies and shows and as far as
the big crossover event goes I think
many people are thinking battleworld
especially since Doctor Strange 2 is
titled Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness so the fact that we're going
to be really diving into the multiverse
here not fake diving into it like Spider
Man far from home but really diving into
it could be setting up battle world and
as I said as far as the New Avengers
team goes we pretty much know who the
New Avengers are going to be in that
same interview Kevin Feige went on to
say that the New Avengers team is going
to consist of members that we have
already met and some that we have not
already met and he concluded his talk
about the New Avengers by saying that
the New Avengers team is going to be
varied
different than we've seen before it
would be a very different incarnation of
the team with some people you've already
met and some people you haven't met yet
so right now we basically know who the
returning Avengers are going to be we
have Captain Marvel who is most likely
going to be leading the new Avengers Sam
or Falcon as Captain America Black
Panther war machine spider-man Thor and
Doctor Strange and Wanda will most
likely be a part of it as well and then
we have the newcomers blade will most
likely be a part of the Avengers and
then we have Lady Jane Thor depending on
her story arc and the way that Thor at
love and thunder in she will most likely
be a part of the New Avengers the same
thing goes with some of the Eternals
they may be a part of the New Avengers
as well and if they're not officially
part of the New Avengers they will
probably help in the crossover event the
same thing goes with the Fantastic Four
they are probably not going to be
official Avengers but just like an
Avengers in game there are going to be
many different heroes in the crossover
events which we will probably see the
Fantastic Four appear in and the same
goes for the x-men as well but this is
just going to be the first initial New
Avengers team the first New Avengers
team from the comics included Luke Cage
Captain America Iron Man spider-man and
spider-woman but then would later go on
to introduce Wolverine century and EKKO
to the team so the same will most likely
happen here we'll get an initial new
Avengers team but as more characters
such as the Fantastic Four and the x-men
get introduced into the MCU they will
also join the new Avengers so the new
Avengers team now and down the line is
going to be super stacked which means
they're going to have to bring in a
really really big villain but Marvel now
owns the rights to many big villains
including Doctor Doom and Galactus so
there shouldn't be any problem there and
again with so many new characters coming
in it seems like everything is lining up
for a battle world event especially
because it seems like the multiverse is
about to play a huge part in the MCU so
Kevin Feige has officially confirmed
that a new Avengers team has been
planned and a huge crossover event is
coming as well who would you like to be
on the New Avengers team and what
crossover event would you like to see in
the MCU be sure to let me know in the
comments and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MC
you as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof